para un proyecto de arte un pentágono
hecho de cartulina es cortado en cinco
partes iguales dos de esas partes fueron
eliminadas escribe la porción que ha
quedado como fracción y para esto vamos
a hacer un pentágono primero vamos a
marcar esto que vamos a hacer un
pentágono es una figura con cinco lados
30 5
y de hecho en eeuu hay un edificio que
está la secretaria de defensa y tiene
justo la forma de un pentágono
vamos a ver qué tal me queda mi
pentágono
no creo que no
vamos a hacer un pentágono haré mi mejor
esfuerzo de verdad que los pentágonos a
veces me cuestan trabajo
creo que si uno de esos puntos quedará
bien
es bastante bien creo que va bien
ok quedó bastante decente vamos a borrar
esta línea y dejemos únicamente nuestro
pentágono este pentágono está hecho de
cartulina vamos a cortarlo digamos que
este es el centro y dice que está en
cinco partes iguales vamos a dividirlo
en cinco partes iguales uno
2 hoy
esto sería nuestra primer parte
la segunda
tercera
cuarta y quinta pensemos que está
perfectamente hecho mi pentágono y que
son cinco partes iguales vamos a ver dos
de estas partes fueron eliminadas voy a
tomar dos partes de este pentágono
pensar en 1
esta primera parte
vamos a eliminar y consideramos esta
segunda parte también como eliminable
dos de las cinco partes iguales fueron
eliminadas describe qué porción
ha quedado como fraction
qué parte ha quedado pues ha quedado
está
y ésta
así es que si cuento una dos tres partes
han quedado
ok tres partes se han quedado sin
embargo nos está diciendo que marquemos
como fracción tres partes de que a pues
han quedado tres partes de estas cinco
totales recuerda que nuestro pentágono
tiene 5
partes iguales
si consideramos todas estas que estoy
marcando en naranja tenemos un total de
5 partes iguales
así es que podemos escribir qué
eran
cinco partes totales
si escribimos esto como fracción podemos
decir que tres partes han quedado de un
total de cinco partes esto lo podemos
escribir como tres quintos
han quedado
de este pentágono
pentágono
o podemos decir que de las cinco partes
totales de los cinco quintos retire dos
dos quintos han retirado y me quedan
tres quintos de la parte del pentágono
así es como lo podemos ver como fracción
recuerda es súper importante que tengan
este concepto porque es uno de los más
útiles que van a tener